we also all as sisters have hummingbird
like it and it's a lucky because her
ashes are actually in it tamar braxton
is revealing how she's keeping her late
sister tracy's memory alive my sisters
are amazing and i love them so much and
the great thing about family is that you
can have disagreements but at the end of
the day you always come back to the core
and that's family while appearing on
dish nation the love and war singer says
that she and her sisters tony trina and
tawanda are taking tracy everywhere they
go we also all as sisters have a
hummingbird like it and it's a lucky
because her ashes are actually in it
yes and we all have one and the reason
being is because she wanted to go
everywhere that we all went i love you
even if i don't have an honest in my
purses in my bag as for the special
meaning behind the bird so she had five
hummingbirds on her back to represent
each one of her sisters yeah and so
she wanted to be a hummingbird and she
looked at us as hummingbirds so here's
to my forever
angel hummingbird tracy died last month
after a year of privately undergoing a
series of treatments for esophageal
cancer she was 50 years old
it's the last
[Music]
the singers rep told et she was
surrounded by her family and friends
when she died a sentiment tomorrow
echoed on the show the truth is my
family is really hanging in there it's
been very difficult if you can imagine
yeah we were just there with her by her
side till the end
and at the time all the braxton sisters
shared their grief on social media the
unbreak my heart singer posted this
tribute along with this black and white
photo with all her sisters tony writes
in the caption she was a bright light a
wonderful daughter an amazing sister a
loving mother wife grandmother and a
respected performer tracy passed this
morning as the snow was falling our
angel is now a snowflake trina shared
tony's post while tawanda wrote this
sweet message to her late sister quote
our morning ritual laughing saying good
morning or even watching the same movie
on the phone in silence no one will ever
know just how we were as sisters as for
tamar she shared an audio clip of a
money long song i wish i had a time
machine writing in the caption my dear
tracy come back i'm blessed that i have
my sisters around me even though they're
nosy as heck but i'm glad that that they
are you know it shows that they're real
concerned about me and my health and my
well-being and one thing is for sure
tracy's bond with her sisters was
unbreakable don't get it twisted any of
my sisters if somebody walk over them
and i don't like it and they don't like
and they hurting really bad oh believe
me i'm going to step in i am that
protector sister to make sure they're
okay you know let them know i have your
back
we will jump up on if we would jump you
we braxtons i mean come on now
[Music]